[Applaudissements]
ok boomer vous avez peut-être déjà
entendu ça la part de la jeune
génération qui s'adresse aux plus
anciens généralement je suis pas fan de
ce genre d'expressions super médiatisé
qui vise à porter la voix de toute une
génération
mais là pour le coup je veux dire que ça
a vraiment résonner ce hoquet boomer
c'est vraiment la volonté d'arrêter les
discours moralisateurs stériles et les
jeux politiques je fais partie de la
première génération à avoir été éveillé
aux enjeux écologiques
je fais partie de ces générations qui
ont dû vivre avec tellement de paradoxe
d'un côté pour être un citoyen
responsable
je dois trier mes déchets je dois
éteindre la lumière quand je sors d'une
pièce je dois aussi atteindre le robinet
quand je me brosse les dents
c'est ce qu'on me disait quand j'étais
petit parce que sinon c'est pas bon pour
la planète mais d'un autre côté je dois
accepter que mon immeuble en plein coeur
de paris ne fasse pas le tri des déchets
parce qu'il ya pas de place pour mettre
les containers même si moi je les trie
je dois accepter que des boutiques
laisse la lumière allumée toute la nuit
alors qu'elles sont fermés juste pour
qu'un admire leur vitrine et je dois
accepter que mes toilettes consomment
plus d'eau potable que moi c'est la
société dans laquelle on vit aujourd'hui
je dis pas qu'il faut pas préserver la
nature c'est important mais la nature
finalement elle a pas besoin de nous la
nature et se répare toute seule elle
s'en remettra nous beaucoup moins on
veut préserver la nature parce qu'on
dépend de la nature notre survie dépend
de la nature et pardonnez moi
l'expression mais on lui en met plein la
gueule pourtant donc finalement je me
pose cette question est ce que est ce
que ce mode il est soutenable encore
encore très longtemps probablement pas
un autre siècle
je suis né dans les années 80 et j'ai
grandi avec tous ces paradoxes
l'image que j'ai de la société là c'est
ce paquet de cigarettes avec marqué
dessus
fumer tue totalement légal totalement
tolérer aucun problème comme le fait de
pas trier ses déchets comme le fait
d'avoir des boutiques fermées qui laisse
la lumière allumée comme le fait que des
toilettes consomment de l'eau potable
aucun problème donc si on veut arriver à
changer ça il va falloir vraiment changé
les lunettes avec lesquels on regarde le
monde
cette société dans laquelle on vit
aujourd'hui on sait qu'elle fonctionnera
plus vraiment très très longtemps
elle fonctionnera plus vraiment très
très longtemps
on le sait
là je suis étonné de ne pas avoir plus
de réactions parce que on a d'un côté
des discours de l'autre côté des actes
qui sont pas du tout dans le même sens
et quand il s'agit d'aller changer la
société
on parle de changer tout le système et
pas simplement pour essayer d'améliorer
les modes de production de consommation
non là on parle vraiment de se préparer
à ce qui nous arrive tout ce qu'on a
engendré au 20e siècle
là on va parler d'eux on va parler de
famine on va parler de montée des eaux
on va parler de crise humanitaire social
on va parler de raréfaction des
ressources
tout ça c'est ce qui nous attend et
cette société pourtant on vit en plein
dans la nature
elle va s'en remettre la nature à
l'hérésie liantes la nature elle est
capable de se remettre de tout il ya
aucun souci nous c'est beaucoup moins un
autre cas
la nature elle favorise en fait
l'adaptation et la collaboration et
elles punissent qui prend trop de place
on prend trop de place quand je dis la
nature je parle pas d'un mécanisme
pensants ou quoi que ce soit la nature
c'est près de 10 millions d'espèces qui
coexistent et qui vivent chacune leur
quotidien mais la nature c'est ce qui
fonctionne depuis près de quatre
milliards d'années la nature elle fait
le tri elle fait le tri elle conserve
que ce qui marche
donc si à un moment donné on veut savoir
comment fonctionner un peu plus en
harmonie avec la nature
il suffit de l'observer les anciens les
peuples qui dépendent beaucoup moins de
la technologie observé beaucoup plus la
nature que nous et s'en inspirer nous on
le sait assez peu finalement et on
réinvente en permanence nos propres
solutions avec le succès qu'on connaît
et cette société-là on le sait elle
arrive en bout de course
on peut s'inspirer de la nature par
exemple on prend les fourmis les fourmis
c'est une population assez fascinante
chez les fourmis
il faut savoir qu'il ya 10% de chômage
est à 10% des fourmis qui ne travaillent
pas et font rien et pourtant elles sont
parfaitement acceptée par les autres
elles ont accès à la nourriture elles
ont accès aux ressources mais elles sont
inactives elles sont acceptées parce
qu'elles sont pourtant utile elle bloque
le passage des autres fourmis et en
bloquant le passage des autres fourmis
elles rendent ces fourmis plus attentive
et plus réactive
il faut savoir que ça ça a pour effet
d'augmenter la productivité de la
colonie de 30%
si on enlève toutes ces petites fourmis
la productivité de la colonie diminue
d'autant
et en plus de ça c'est un avantage
évolutif puisque en obligeant les
fourmis est tout le temps en état d'
alerte
en fait elles repèrent plus facilement
les menaces et donc elles survivent plus
facilement la nature nous apprend que
l'inactivité c'est pas l'inutilité c'est
un exemple dont on pourrait s'inspirer
dans nos propres sociétés
un autre exemple intéressant c'est celui
du corps humain on le sait on à des
bactéries on a des bactéries sur notre
peau on a des bactéries dans nos organes
et on sait qu'on en a beaucoup
ce concept être moins ce que ces
bactéries ça représente plus de 500
espèces différentes et surtout ce qu'on
sait généralement encore moins c'est
qu'il ya plus de cellules étrangères il
ya plus de bactéries qui composent notre
corps que de cellules humaines pour que
tout ça ça fonctionne correctement il
faut plus de cellules étrangères que de
cellules d'origine
le biomimétisme organisationnel c'est
regarder ce genre de choses et se
demander comment ça pourrait s'adapter
dans notre monde à nous puisque la
nature c'est ce qui fonctionne on
pourrait l'appliquer dans les
entreprises demain par exemple on voit
que c'est une tendance qui commence
lentement lentement à émerger et se dire
que demain une entreprise qui fonctionne
c'est une entreprise dans laquelle il ya
plus de collaborateurs qui ne sont pas
salariés que de salariés
mais si on pousse un peu plus loin on
pourrait l'appliquer pourquoi pas pour
pour l'immigration
attention là je vois les gens sérieux
arrivé tout de suite monsieur la mort y
voyons l'immigration c'est un sujet
sérieux qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
les 200 millions d'africains qui vont
arriver à nos frontières d'ici 2050 on
regarde les fourmis avec eux non parce
que bon ça va pas marcher
non c'est plus compliqué que ça et là
j'ai envie de dire ok boomer c'est
compliqué simplement parce qu'on essaye
de préserver à tout prix un modèle de
société qui tient plus la route
la société dans laquelle on vit
c'est la société du 20e siècle
aujourd'hui il faut qu on chausse les
lunettes du 21e siècle des lunettes qui
nous permette de vivre avec les autres
espèces dans la nature en parfaite
collaboration 99,9 pour cent des espèces
qui ont existé un jour sont éteintes
aujourd'hui les 0,1 pour cent des
espèces qui reste c'est à dire ce que
l'on peut voir aujourd'hui c'est celle
qui sont collaborative et qui se sont
adaptés
donc la seule chose que j'ai envie de
dire c'est que le 21e siècle c'est le
siècle on doit renouer avec la nature
puisque le 20e siècle est celui qui nous
a le plus éloigné de cette nature et que
renouer avec la nature bas c'est
ressembler un peu plus au zéro virgule
1% des espèces qui s'adapte et
collaborent et pour les autres ok boomer
merci
[Applaudissements]